pues ya que somos muy buenos con estas
anti derivadas o estas integrales que
son la operación de inversa a la regla
de la potencia de la derivada entonces
agarre esta integral muy peluda muy loca
muy extravagante y que parece ser muy
llamativa que tenemos aquí y es lo que
quiero que resolvamos en este momento y
lo primero que voy a hacer es separar
esta integral separarla en pedacitos es
decir como tengo es la suma de una
integral voy a agarrar la suma de cada
una de las integrales y bueno mi primer
sumando es este por lo tanto me queda la
integral de 7x cúbica diferencial de x
fíjense que el diferencial de x
multiplica a todos los sumandos por lo
tanto lo estoy distribuyendo después
tengo la integral de éste que es
negativa por lo tanto me queda menos la
integral de cinco veces la raíz de x y
esto por de x y después hay que
aumentarle la integral del siguiente
sumando que es este de aquí más la
integral de 18 raíz de x / x cúbica y
todo esto por d
y se me están acabando los colores
necesito este color nuevo muy bien y a
todo esto hay que agregarle la suma de
la última integral es decir la suma de
la integral de x elevado a la menos 40
diferencial de x muy bien y ahora lo que
voy a hacer es resolver cada una de las
integrales de se cuenta que es mucho más
sencillo resolver cada uno de los
pedacitos que tenemos aquí y bueno mi
primer integral me dice la integral de
7x cúbica diferencial de x y como lo
vimos en el vídeo pasado las constantes
pueden salir por lo tanto lo único que
tengo que hacer es aumentarle 1 la
potencia y dividirlo entre ese mismo
número y bueno en este caso particular
la potencia es 3 por lo tanto voy a
sumarle 1 la potencia 3 más uno es 4
entonces me quedaría x elevado a la 4 y
todo esto entre 4 y después hay que
multiplicarlo por el 7 que no se nos
olvide la constante que tenemos aquí al
lado por lo tanto me queda 7 x elevado a
la 4 entre 4
después la siguiente integral es
negativa por lo tanto le voy a poner un
menos y me queda cinco veces la integral
de raíz de x diferencial de x y como
saco la integral de una raíz usando las
leyes de los exponentes hay una ley de
los exponentes que me dice que esto es
lo mismo que 5 veces x elevada a la un
medio y si tengo 5 veces x elevado a una
potencia pues entonces me fijo que la
potencia es un medio le sumo uno la
potencia un medio más un medio más un
medio me da tres medios es decir x
elevada tres medios y todo esto hay que
dividirlo entre la potencia es decir
tres medios y después multiplicarlo por
cinco no vayamos a olvidar este 5 que
tenemos aquí y ahora tengo la siguiente
expresión que dice más la integral de 18
raíz de x / x cúbica caramba como
resuelvo esta integral bueno para esto
voy a simplificar los exponentes esto es
lo mismo que 18 x sale un medio que
multiplica a x elevada a la menos 3
recuerden que las potencias que están
dividiendo cuando pase la variable hacia
arriba
con signo negativo y por lo tanto esto
es lo mismo que 18 x a la un medio menos
3 un medio menos 3 es lo mismo que 2
enteros un medio negativo y bueno esto
es exactamente lo mismo si pasamos la
fracción a fracción impropia que 18 por
equis elevado a las 5 medios negativos y
aquí me falta un signo aquí perdón
perdón es menos 3x menos 2 enteros un
medio y menos 5 medios y ahora si tengo
18 que es una constante x elevada a una
potencia por lo tanto con esta reducción
que acabo de hacer puedo utilizar la
integral que hemos venido usando y la
integral dice sumarle 1 a la potencia y
divide lo entre ese mismo número
entonces menos 5 medios más un medio más
un medio es lo mismo que menos cinco más
uno más uno que es tres medios negativos
esto entre menos tres medios negativos
la potencia tal cual menos tres medios
negativos ya esto hay que multiplicarlo
por 18 y el signo era positivo y bueno
yo sé que esta expresión
reducir un poco pero ahorita lo voy a
hacer en el siguiente paso después tengo
x elevada a la menos 40 por lo tanto
tiene una potencia y voy a hacer lo
mismo
tengo que sumarle 1 la potencia entonces
me queda x elevada a la menos 39 entre
menos 39 y el signo positivo y después
de todo esto no olviden aumentarle la
constante de integración y ahora lo que
voy a hacer es reducir un poco esta
expresión 7 entre 4 se queda igual no se
puede reducir y me queda 7 cuartos de x
elevado a la 4 y después tengo menos 5
entre 3 medios que cuánto es 5 entre 3
medios es lo mismo que 5 veces uno entre
tres medios que es dos tercios y esto es
lo mismo que diez tercios por lo tanto
me quedan menos diez tercios de x
elevado a la tres medios hice una ley
del sándwich y después aquí tengo lo
mismo tengo 18 entre menos tres medios
por lo tanto voy a utilizar lo mismo 18
entre menos tres medios es lo mismo que
18 por menos dos tercios y esto es lo
mismo que menos
18 entre 3 y 6 por 2 es decir menos 12 y
estoy dividiendo entre 3 para que sea
mucho más fácil y no multiplicar el 18
por el 2 entonces todo esto me queda
menos 12 que multiplica a x elevada a la
menos 3 medios vamos a escribirlo con
morado menos 12 x elevado a la menos 3
medios y después hay que sumarle uno no
no hay que restarle porque más x menos
es menos 1 entre 39 de x elevado a la
menos 39 ya esto hay que agregarle una
constante de integración y hemos acabado
perfecto ya tenemos la anti derivada de
toda esta locura que yo tenía que ir y
me da de resultado esto te encargó que
derive toda esta expresión para que veas
que en efecto me va a dar de resultado
toda esta locura y esta expresión peluda
que teníamos aquí arriba